Instead of calculating precision and
recall individually and
looking at each to make a decision as
to the performance of a classifier,
we can actually use at something
called the F-beta score.
This is the general definition
of the F-`beta score.
The beta here can have various values,
depending on how much weight
one wants to give to the precision
value over the recall value.
Using a combination of precision and
recall, such as the F-beta score,
can be very helpful because it gives you
one number to maximize rather than two.
If you're trying to decide
between two different models and
one has a higher precision but
a lower recall, which will you choose?
One method would be to choose
the model with the higher area under
the ROC curve.
Another method would be to choose
the model with the higher F-beta score.
Now let's try to set beta equals 1.
Setting beta equals 1, you can see that
the F1 score is given by this formula.
This is simply the harmonic
mean of precision and recall.
This kind of mean protects against
comparatively high values of
one of these against the other.
The F1 score thus weighs
the precision and recall equally.
One can use different values of beta
that give different weights
to precision and recall.
Much like the loss function,
the choice of beta here depends on the
specific problem under consideration.
We want to do a quick quiz on
your understanding of F scores.
In each of the following
scenarios which choice of F1,
F0.5, or
F2 be the best choice of metric?
First we look at cancer detection.
If someone is falsely diagnosed,
we may do some extra tests.
If someone who actually has cancer
is not diagnosed, they may die.
In the box give your appropriate choice.
The second example is
convicting to prison.
People are innocent until
proven guilty by US law.
We want to avoid false convictions, but
we also want criminals to not run free.
In this case,
what sort of F score will we use?